speaking of back shots
let's let's go back and look at some
shots I don't know there's really no way
to tee this up uh there's a there's a
way to Tee It Up yeah there was a there
was a PSA made about us yeah but why
well I think we should just let him see
[Music]
yeah
gold it's just you're gonna have a lot
of fun with those
[Music]
this is Jewel
oh yeah the coolest one look at the
coolest [__]
that's good that's good
just got me re-addicted to that
cigarettes yeah
so yeah
that wasn't cool man we saw this we took
it to heart and um
it doesn't it doesn't look no like it
doesn't look sexy no not at all no
um it doesn't subtly make you look kind
of just I don't know a little edgy and
yeah it's not like a super [__]
thing to do no at all
now
um it's not the type of thing that makes
you like want to like um you know
what
you know when you see someone smoking
and you're just like yeah you want to
like do gay porn with them yeah oh what
I wasn't even okay okay
we had um a hilarious comment it was
totally valid but so funny lighting up
actual cigarettes in your studio taking
an actual puff then actually looking
into the camera and actually exclaiming
that's good
one of the most [__] up things I never
thought I'd imagine someone from our
generation doing it's it's barely a joke
if that's the defense you're going to
use for glorifying cigarettes within the
first two minutes of the episode this
must be what the kids call lost in the
sauce and yes I just renewed my
subscription to say that it's worth ten
dollars
like what what are what we're not in the
year 1995 you know we are in 2023. it's
like cigarettes are not cool everyone
knows that and nobody wants to yeah
cigarettes yeah dude I I guarantee we
convinced zero people to pick up a
cigarette I know but here's the thing
it's 20 23 right yeah we didn't convince
anyone to smoke cigarettes right right
but you know what's really good is carts
carts tasteful yeah they're all smoking
them already they're like you know
what's good fentanyl oh all right
I'm kidding if you're selling it you're
on the good side yeah exactly
I just like here's the thing about
cigarettes is it is they are good hot
like it is fun to smoke a cigarette I
actually genuinely love it but it's it's
horrible for you it makes you feel
horrible the next morning when you're
coughing up [__] tar you know
but like the like actually smoking a
cigarette is very enjoyable and I like
it so I was just being honest I'm not
glorifying anything to anyone that's
just my opinion yeah
yeah no I did I love this what I just I
just let no I like to see you stand on
this I'm just saying if you want to try
a cigarette try it
no one listened to that and was like oh
I think I'll switch from my watermelon
[__] buffer to that my my watermelon
Tesla battery yeah exactly
Tesla battery just
yeah the smallest tip
sorry I'm a little delirious I didn't
sleep a lot less oh it's fine so am I
having a panic attack half half of one
yeah so we're a little off how'd you do
it's still going that's what I'm saying
oh yeah you got it right now well it's
just like my it's just one of those
mornings it's one of those days you know
no you just don't oh my God he said she
said [__] I'm just driving here
tweaking out yeah you know yeah it's
such a beautiful day yeah it is down
there driving down to the hatch to the
to the submarine
man we gotta get less sleep in you
you know I like this but it's old news
by now anyways this goes out in two
weeks yeah it's I know because it was
two weeks ago
yeah dude right right dude yeah right
right you wanna do some personal
reflecting this episode sure just
because you haven't had a panic attack
you want to get deep one just like just
go at full existential crisis right now
no I don't you want to go down I'm
already feeling short of breath just
thinking about that don't you love like
the coffee panic attack before sleep
yeah that's like the good one yeah I
love it you're like well that's that's
what I'm getting this morning I don't do
that before sleep because wait you drink
coffee before before sleep no no
sometimes I feel like a total idiot yeah
that's what I'm saying you know but this
is the same thing I do in the morning
I'll drink like one more than I'm
supposed to yeah because I know this is
gonna this is literally gonna give me a
panic attack and I look at it I'm like
but it's so good it's like cigarettes
yeah it's like cigarettes it's fun it's
cool it's sexy you want to do it more
just try it yeah
laughs
yeah I just don't know who looks at us
and is like they're smoking yeah I want
to do it I think people see us smoke and
they're like yeah cigarettes are kind of
corny yeah you know what I mean like
exactly exactly we're smoking these are
hemp cigarettes they're not even
handbats
there's not even any tobacco in there or
anything bad yeah I just posted about
doing an Iron Man for like a year
straight like you really think I'm
smoking cigarettes out here hey man
there are Fighters that smoke that
there's been Fighters that have smoked
between rounds
back in the day though yeah that's
that's again that's like a late 90s
thing to do early 2000s late 90s you
think I was thinking more like the 50s I
think people worse no my parents smoked
like when I was young no no yes when I
was young or maybe right before I think
they quit around when I was born but
like er like late 90s is I guess when
everything started right when I was born
your mom's just pregnant like
I should probably chill on this yeah
yeah sorry she definitely quit before
she was pregnant with me but my dad I
don't know but I know they both used to
smoke because everyone did
you're fresh out the womb yeah yeah
umbilical cord's still attached she's
like God damn I need to you mine yeah
Jesus [__] this this takes a while dude
hold on hold on don't cut it yet
[Laughter]
smoke comes out my nose
it goes through the umbilical cord and
the dark the doctor pulls down his
[__] mask and he's had a cigarette in
there the whole time
walking this kid man [__]
jeez what's that out on the umbilical
umbilical cord yeah and then they didn't
get all the way through and then the
assistant pulls on his mask I got it
singed that off yeah damn so I'm not
smoking
but um I have in the past I used to
smoke we were saying smoking late 80s
90s I guess mid 90s is when all like the
ads started coming out I feel like
they're like but smoking and
establishments when did that stop look
that up
like like
that was like early 2000s wasn't it yeah
I guess we're like two thousand yeah
because there's there's still there used
to be smoking sections everywhere 95.
what about in other places 2010 yeah it
was I remember it was in college when
they when they stopped smoking indoors
halfway through college in North
Carolina they were like okay you can't
smoke in restaurants anymore
um and we're all like oh what yeah
no I'm kidding everyone at at the stroke
of midnight they all waited in a diner
to celebrate yeah exactly it was the
last cigarette and then at midnight
there they all just took that hit and
just on the floor yeah
yeah
big old pile